[Music]
hey everyone what's up welcome to
simulation today we have a very very
special episode we have vas per systems
in the house
yeah yeah with peter and sebastian
Wasowski mm-hmm the cofounders yes so
much for having this pleasure to be here
thank you
I'm really excited so you guys are
bringing a tremendous amount of
experience to this industry and it's
really hacking into human performance in
human health peter has 35 year
background in medical technology and
vascular health
correct it's actually more than that
it's more than that now yeah I'm 70 now
so it's 47 years
you look very damn good for 70 thank you
yeah that's right and you're like that's
right I know I'm gonna be like that too
yeah yeah and so so give me a little bit
of a background into the meta into this
medical tech industry and vascular
health industry so you've been working
on this for over 35 years what have been
these moments of okay the system looks
this way currently how can we figure out
how to hack it to enhance human health
and performance now so this actually we
started the company in 2009 but I have
been working on the sort of a kitchen
side of medicine for 47 years and
assisting in designing products and then
designing a couple of my own products
prior to this so those so the the most
recent one before that is a the company
is called cool systems the product that
they have out there right now is called
game ready and and this was where we
commercialized the NASA cooling
technology because once you put an
astronaut into a spacesuit of course
sweating does not work because there's
no heat no air exchange so the only way
to cool an astronaut is was liquid
cooling mm-hmm and actually liquid is a
is a temperature conductor where air is
at temperature insulators so it works
better as well so we designed a piece of
equipment back then this was in 1996
that was designed to heal the joints
after injury and that company was sold
to Leigh Steinberg if you've seen the
movie Jerry Maguire
was Tom Cruise that was based on his
life story and and he renamed the
product game ready and they're quite
well known in professional sports and a
lot of amateur sports as well and you
mentioned that for astronauts it's an
air is an insulating cooling system so
you can't actually use air Corona can
use liquid yes and that's one of those
so with NASA being right there Bhaskar
is located right next to NASA Ames well
we are at NASA and NASA and we are
actually the technical name for the
space where we are is called NASA
research it's a NASA NASA NASA research
park yeah and our key and that's where a
lot of the Space Shuttle components were
built and there's still tremendous
amount of research going on there
supporting small satellites micro
satellites that go up in large swarms
and
look at asteroids and things like that
so it's a very very active center a lot
of amazing scientists we've had a six
year research agreement with NASA to
develop this technology for space travel
or to reduce the amount of time that
astronauts use in space currently they
exercise over two hours every day yeah
so you are these strapping in now and
the ISS are they you know but hopefully
will soon you know as soon as is a very
delicate term when you talk about any
kind of government projects I think
private space industry has demonstrated
very rapid advances in a short amount of
time so we we hope to work with them as
well so then now the technology is
coming into the homes of people that can
exercise and also athletes also
hospitals all these different locations
tell us a little bit about that yeah I
mean we are across the board on one end
of the spectrum or with Special Forces
professional athletes NASA astronauts
and on the other end of the spectrum is
being utilized in cardiac rehab
geriatrics physical therapy and then
everybody in between so our oldest
clients are in their late 90s using this
on a regular basis and then some of the
world's top athletes and Special Forces
guys on the other end of the spectrum
Wow a lot of different people using this
and using it to hack into their
performance and their health so the
system that you've built now this is a
very classic exercise bike right the
bikes classic and then what is different
is the cooling the liquid cooling system
and then the proprietary software
component as well yeah those two things
mix together including compression as
well as very specific interval protocols
that we've developed
yes so we the idea is to be a force
multiplier for exercise so normally when
you exercise for an hour let's say it
takes you at least the same time to
recover from that and of course it
usually involves showers and and is like
extended recovery time where we can
you're on the bike for 21 minutes this
is a 20-minute interval exercise with
one-minute cooling and then 10-minute
cooling on a table and you're totally
recovered so and you don't need to take
a shower so a lot of the side effects
such as sweating discomfort and long
recovery we removed and we actually
enhanced the benefit of exercise so we
make the brain think that you just ran
up a giant mountain and did CrossFit on
top of it
and the brain responds as though you did
so any doctor will tell you that
exercise is the best form of medicine
yeah and most people actually don't
exercise enough yes some over exercise
and this is seems to be an ideal
platform for anybody from as young as
nine years old towards all those ninety
seven years old with you know
professional athletes and military can
use this platform and benefit
tremendously yeah so the cooling in
compression so we're gonna have we're
gonna for total cooling and compression
straps yeah we're gonna have one on each
bicep and then we're and that's gonna be
this motion and then we're gonna have
one on each side on each quad and
hamstring and then that's gonna be for
this motion with the legs yeah so what
the whole system is designed to do is to
stimulate your body's production of
anabolic hormones
all right let's unpack that for us
anabolic hormone yes so these are the
hormones for any type of turnover
rebuilding regeneration in the body who
they require anabolic hormones the
primary one
produced by pituitary gland is growth
hormone mm-hmm so we tend to see it
decline about 14 percent every ten years
past puberty Wow and that's what most
people would consider to be just normal
aging yeah you know there's a there's a
saying in anti aging that our hormones
don't decline because we age we age
because our hormones decline uh-huh and
the way that you fight that trend is
through exercise but specifically
intensive anaerobic exercise because
it's only through high intensity
exercise that we actually stimulate our
body's production of growth hormone and
other anabolic hormones so that's
arguably the single greatest most
significant benefit of exercise vascular
as a means of initiating that benefit
through a much lower threshold than is
normally involved yeah okay so we're
gonna be so this cooling compression is
gonna be stimulating the production of
anabolic hormones and is that gonna
start as soon as the cooling and the
exercise begins or does that usually
come after pain about hormones come
after so this is something that the you
know the basic principle behind this
technology could be is known as
biomimicry imitating nature mm-hmm so
what we're doing here is we're imitating
a physiology that you'll naturally see
in children so whenever you see four
five six seven year-olds you don't see
those people walking they're always
going full speed ahead if you were to
look inside their quads yeah you would
see very highly concentrated amount of
lactic acid and the reason concentration
is high is because the legs are small
the bodies are small and they they're
always in motion so the lactic acid is
the waste product or the muscle tissue
being used and the higher the
concentration not the amount the higher
the concentration of lactic acid the
stronger the feedback to the brain
specifically to the pituitary gland
requesting additional growth hormone
levels to rebuild those muscles back to
pre exercise condition interesting so
children of course do this all the time
and one day run our situation
lactic acid but not adults have a lower
concentration of lactic acid until we
exercise and then we get a higher
concentration ok well that's very true
what you just said is very true I would
like to sort of unpack it a little bit
so whenever you see children and they
run around all day they sleep very well
at night at night between the second and
third stage of sleep just before your
REM sleep cycle the brain produces 50%
of our daily hormone levels 50% that's a
lot so most people do not get it this is
why the energy drink business is doing
so well and coffee business is doing so
well because we need to basically
kickstart the brain when we wake up in
the morning and get the pressure up
which caffeine does quite well yeah yeah
of course children never ask you for
coffee when they get up right they're
full of energy and they do it all over
again so what we're basically doing with
this technology is mimicking or
duplicating a similar physiology in an
adult body that you see naturally
occurring in a child so by putting
compression on the upper legs quads and
biceps and putting you through this
exercise protocol we are preventing the
lactic acid escaping from the muscle by
compressing it therefore we're
concentrating and under the compression
hacking the brain basically that you
just destroyed the muscle today or in
fact you did not go there it could give
me more growth hormone exactly and
normally the lactic acid is escaping
it's being swept away by the venous
system by the route them through out
this all right ok and that's why you
normally need 60 minutes to how to get a
concentration of lactic acid but if you
can compress and cool you can hack the
brain into getting you that growth
hormone faster well it depends how many
minutes you need depends on the type of
exercise you do but the bottom line is
that intense very intense exercise and
aerobic exercise especially also leads
to overtraining because then you're
basically damaging your
yeah Cartledge you're damaging some of
those other tissues in your body and and
there's some injuries that are tied to
to this so with this platform this is
sort of like an anti overtraining device
because we hack the brain into thinking
you damage the body tissues where you
haven't the brain is responding with
this additional as Sebastian said
anabolic hormones hormones that we build
your body and you can actually use that
for additional energy to be your top
performer during a competition and you
sleep much better because it lowers your
nighttime stress hormone plus a lot of
other health related benefits without
their damage now that does not mean that
this replaces conventional exercise yeah
this is a very great foundational
platform but once you do that first yes
the other exercise you just you're just
much much better at it because you
recover faster you have more energy more
strength you have more blood oxygen on
board yes it just goes much better
because then there are all the other
muscle groups of our body like our lads
and our calves and our triceps and our
forearms traps there's so many other
areas of our body that still need to get
exercise that that can be targeted at a
later time as well this is a vascular
component at a foundational level of
exercise it's really important yeah so
this is the primary principle behind it
there's another secondary principle
that's very important to mention and
that is the temperature control so
normally when we exercise we sweat and
there's a tremendous and a lot of blood
that goes to the surface of the skin in
order for us to sweat the skin is the
biggest organ in the body six and a half
million pores and each one of us has a
very finite amount of blood on board
which happens to be close to 8% of your
body weight so if you're looking at a
hundred pound person there's eight
pounds of blood they're slightly more
than a gallon if that person is
exercising with intensity conventionally
exercising a lot of that blood goes to
the surface of the skin which means you
don't have enough blood at the muscle
level where you need it and this is why
if when you finish intense exercise you
have delayed onset of muscle soreness
you have so muscles for a day or so
because there was not enough blood there
to remove the lactic acid therefore it
gets stored in the muscle tissue until
it can be removed through the vascular
system and the concentration helps the
blood drive to that area to help remove
the lactic acid no no no so so I'm still
learning yeah it's still learning so
just stay with me for a second
so there's two there's two negatives of
all there's two negative side effects of
conventional exercise if it's if it's
done with a lot of intensity so one is
that you have residual lactic acid in a
muscle tissue the second one is that
your whole core body temperature goes up
and blood temperature goes up as well so
blood is mostly water so imagine if you
heat water you can actually see the
oxygen escaping if you heat water long
enough it'll disappear so on a different
scale the same thing happens with a
blood stream so as our temperature goes
up and look at the hundred pound person
with you know eight percent which is
eight pounds of water the of blood
slightly more than a gallon that blood
actually goes up in temperature and it
starts blowing off blood oxygen blood
oxygen is what the muscles live on so
the less blood oxygen you have on board
the quicker you will not be able to
perform so in normal athletic terms you
hit the wall you can no levan perform in
scientific terms you hit what's called
the vo2 max you hit the ability to
metabolize oxygen once that happens your
performance goes south so what we're
doing here is by by cooling you on the
on the during the exercise we're cooling
your back the back of your pelvis we're
pulling the compression areas we're also
cooling your feet yes the reason we call
your feet is when you're under a hot
blanket and your stick your foot out
when you're too hot right so your feet
are your thermostats and radiators when
we cool all these parts of anatomy we
are preventing the core body temperature
from going up yeah which means that all
the blood is at the muscle level because
you're not sweating or minimal sweating
so normally the blood goes to the skin
level like you're explaining exactly ER
because you're getting really hot that's
right and the process of respiration
involves blood being shunted to the
surface of the skin and then you lose
blood within the muscle you lose oxygen
in the muscle and that's the fuel that
you need to perform so from an athletic
perspective you're always going to
perform better in a cooler environment
an example of this is they compiled
marathon data and found that 51 degrees
was actually optimal environmental
temperature for human performance Wow
which is much colder than what most
people would expect now that and that
temperature will go up for a shorter
race I mean that's over 26 miles but it
still highlights the fact that when
we're cooler when the blood is in the
working muscle as opposed to
facilitating preparation we're
performing at a higher level from an
athletic standpoint and when you walk
out the door initially it might be
really cold but then once you get
running it feels really good right
you're not sweating as much at 51
degrees not that concentration of Bloods
in your muscles and oxygens and your
muscles exactly you're retaining more
oxygen which enables you to perform at a
higher level so the cooling here enables
the user to be as powerful as possible
and as efficient as possible for the
twenty one minute protocol driving a
stronger physiology for ultimately the
desired effect which is optimizing your
hormonal profile let's do it yeah let's
do it so this is already cooled it's not
turned on does it only turn into the
waters in here though the water is in
there so water okay so let's let's let's
just do a quick a quick bit on on this
real quick so so this asks this part is
cooling the water correct and then it's
sending it through to the different to
the back the pelvis the arm and the off
row coughs there's a supply and a return
so you can see there's two cords going
to all the surfaces of cooling and that
includes the
the footpads as well as each cuff so
there's cold water going in we're able
to maintain a pressure that we set for
each limb and then the water is also
coming out so it's circulating around
the limb as well as through the seat as
well as through the knot of the pants
yeah that's yeah that's what enables for
a more effective heat exchange that's
what gonna enable you to be as powerful
as possible for the 21 minutes because
the cold is you have cold the cold water
running through and then as it absorbs
into my body then the hot water will
come back out and they'll get recalled
and it's a cycle it's a constant motion
and how do you how do you know
oh is it split down the middle so then
it runs on this side and it loops back
around and then options right it's
actually cool all right
the water's gonna be about 40 to 45
degrees in temperature okay yeah this is
like swimming without getting wet
swimming without getting wet yeah there
you go yeah
all right the benefit of a cool swimming
pool awesome
yeah we can put that I'm can strap it in
so I'll let Sebastian take you through
okay sounds good Peter well if Sebastian
do that and then we'll talk to you more
soon awesome turn off the nerf it's
alright go ahead put your feet in the
pedal put in the pedal so we're gonna
start with the right leg at the right
quad we want this as high as possible
okay quad we want to create as much real
estate as we can between the end of the
cuff and the top of the knee okay
someone come to you here
yo then let's go as high up as possible
yes please awesome
okay cool so there's like a whole
there's a little metal bar that yes so
that enables you to put it on yourself
if you're you know okay if you own one
of these let's try it let's try that on
the another on the other I'll share
okay okay so now we put it up high this
is right next to the shoulder right into
the shoulder on the bicep let's try and
put the this other one on okay so see
okay so now we're gonna go slide all the
way up throw it in to this loop we want
this tube kind of right in a line with
the IT boom and then coming off the side
of the hip is that about in mind yeah it
looks good
okay and then so if you grab the handle
on direction with that and then the
other one with the flap and you kind of
wrap it around yeah like this yeah okay
oh I see so it tightens it with this got
it and then you pull it down like that
yeah okay that's good wrap that's good
wrap yeah okay it was tight tight enough
alright and the high high up enough
looks like and we get the last one on
here okay cool
you work out pretty regularly at least a
decent amount of like like a bodyweight
exercise and and running in yoga gotcha
decent but not enough okay yeah it
starts right here that's what we do for
you guys that simulation we host lots of
shows and I need to work out more so
alright so you're gonna feel interesting
some cooling and some pressures start to
fill into the cuffs right now so I'm
already starting to feel the cold water
come in you can see it right here coming
in yep yeah so I'm feeling pressure
right now on all on all four of the cuff
so it so is the pressure also coming
with is it coming mostly from the water
or is there added air pressure as you
know it's all water it's all water
pressure and that's really what
separates us from any other blood flow
restriction
technologies that are on the market yeah
yeah there's a huge differentiation
there in not only the cooling and the
liquid chilled element but the fact that
we're covering a much wider surface area
with a lesser compression gradient and
then instead of combining blood flow
restriction with you know light load
weightlifting at 20 percent of your one
rep max yeah actually combining it with
a 21 minute dynamic interval based
workout so the synergy between all those
elements is extremely powerful it really
it's already starting to feel really
good I'm right here on my back and my
pelvis as well so I'm gonna shift II
forward here just to get a feel for the
cuff I want to let it fill up just a
little bit more before we get started
the way this protocol is structured how
do you know yeah how to how to write put
in the right amount of light pressure
and arm pressure so there there is a
governor there's sort of a max that you
want to go yeah I turned it up a little
bit just for the sake of it filling up
faster oh but we're gonna just keep you
at 70 right 70 on light pressure 50 on
arm pressure exactly okay yeah
and we typically don't exceed 80 in the
legs or 55 in the arms yeah yeah yeah
okay so the way the protocol is
structured is there's going to be a
seven minute warm-up followed by seven
Sprint's alternating between 30 and 15
seconds Ron are you able to see the
screen cool so then so then as you see
the time elapses are here on the x axis
and on the y axis is the level of
intensity yeah so you guys so the first
seven minutes is a warm-up exam and then
it goes into high-intensity interval
training just on the second 14 minutes
so then we're gonna have a period of 30
seconds of high-intensity than a break
yeah then a slower part and then a 15
seconds of super high intensity and then
a break so okay so you're still you're
leveraging the high-intensity interval
training as well absolutely yeah so the
science behind interval training is
amazing and we're banking on some of
that existing science you know
conjunction with the cooling with the
compression and that's really what makes
this one of the most powerful fitness
and rehabilitation technologies in
existence seven-minute warmup
followed by seven Sprint's alternating
between 30 and 15 seconds the red line
represents your power output that's
right you want to try to plot that red
line in between these parallel yellow
lines throughout the whole workout
because that's the ideal amount of
wattage that I should be outputting it's
it's sort of like a target zone so we
know you're working hard enough to
create enough lactate you concentrate
that and drive the effect that yes so in
so you gotta put an output at least a
certain amount of output in here for for
you for the lactic acid to concentrate
to high enough levels in your muscles to
get the full experience of the 70 minute
but yeah this can be customized for any
level of fitness any level of endurance
so I set you up on like a pretty good
protocol today I feel like you're up to
it let's do it and then you know if you
were a 96 year old with a hip
replacement this exact protocol could be
customized for for your that level of
endurance and we have school awesome
yeah awesome so then then that's what
you that's why you have all the
different styles of people that are
using this from 9 to 97 if you can
benefit from exercise if you can benefit
from movement then you are our client
yes so that's 99.999% of people I'd say
let's do it
alright you ready yup so go ahead and
start moving back and forth there it is
alright so we see that red line coming
up yeah so I need to go a little bit
harder into that you up into that range
nice I'm sorry I think anywhere between
60 and 150 60 in 150 she's a pretty wide
arrange so okay perfect you're in
between the two interesting so this is
the warm-up pace this is yeah we can
have some fun with this race yeah yeah
oh yeah so I first saw you guys at the
Tony Robbins unleash the power within in
San Jose yeah and I was really really
grateful to have been introduced to
Chloe and your team and your machine up
there because I immediately thought
because there was a bunch of other
biohacking stuff up there like like a
like a cryo chamber and stuff like that
and I noticed your machine and I
immediately talked to you guys about
about it cuz I thought it was very
innovative and like what's going on and
and I'm happy that it's you know Tony
obviously cares a lot about trying to
hack human performance and help so it
seemed like a really good fit you guys
to be working with him and now he has a
couple of these machines and he does
yeah yeah he's such an amazing guy and
if you look at his schedule and how
intensive his travel is and the amount
of energy that he has to put out at
these events you know changing lives all
around the world you know being able to
maintain that vitality he has a lot of
different methods of doing so and we're
you know couldn't be happier that vaster
is now one of those official methods
hell yeah so we were lucky enough to
showcase vaster at UPW san jose which
was a fantastic event whoo and then I
just came back from London where we did
the same thing and upw London awesome
equally incredible so yeah very very
blessed to know Tony and for him to be a
fan of what we're doing yeah yeah and
now you have other athletes that are
involved other people that really need
this for their health absolutely that's
so great yeah you're making a direct
impact on people's lives 100% yeah yeah
I know I mean it's it's been quite the
journey over the last 10 years of
getting it to where it is today but the
the scientific validation that the
the traction and the momentum behind the
technology has never been stronger
so it's absolutely an exciting time for
us there's a growing number of medical
professionals medical institutions that
are recognizing how revolutionary this
is and incorporating it into their
practice into their offering and then a
rapidly growing number of professional
sports teams and athletes performance
organizations who are seeing the same
benefits so it's a lot of fun meeting
these people it's a lot of fun making a
direct impact you know but the most
rewarding group to work with yes
anybody who lacks the physical capacity
to engage in high-intensity exercise
yeah it's it's really for them that
those are some of the most powerful case
studies that we have did you bring them
into the 20 minute interval instead of
the 60 minute one
oh it's they in many cases people you
know due to illness
condition injury they just simply lack
the physical capacity to ever be able to
mimic the physiology or create the
physiology of an intensive anaerobic
areas so they're essentially missing out
on that downstream anabolic effect it's
entirely out of reach to them based on
whatever physical limitations that they
have and that's what Peter was
mentioning earlier is that you guys are
bio mimicking the physiological effects
precisely yeah yeah so when when they
come on some of the case studies and and
the impact that it can have even in the
matter of four or five sessions is
absolutely you know yeah it's hard to
even put into words and some of it
sounds like unbelievable but we've been
really really blessed to work with a lot
of people and have a direct impact so so
what is this number one feeling that
people are getting when they're
finishing up because you see we were
mentioning people that have health
that's unable to get to those high
intensity interval physiologies yeah
what what do they say when they're done
with you
so the most common and immediate
benefits the people report using this
system the most common one across all
demographics is major improvement to
quality of sleep
helliya which is really really excited
and
like Peter mentioned earlier it's
between the second and third stage of
the REM cycle that half our growth
hormone is released 54 ow so for anybody
that is lacking quality sleep and
effectively making it through that REM
cycle you are essentially missing out on
half of their bodies rejuvenate okay
okay so now let's let's break that down
more so so if if people are missing the
REM stage between 2 and 3 there are
cycles between 2 & 3 yeah so if people
miss that then they're missing on their
growth hormones half half of their
potential growth hormone release only
occurs then so that's why quality of
sleep is absolutely paramount in every
facet of health and let me check in with
you really quickly
yeah we're 5 minutes in or 5 minutes in
we're almost at the fun part yeah are
you feeling some of that burn in the
quads I'm feeling some of the burn in
the quads and in the bicep awesome yes
and it's great when we have it in both
places the quads is where we have the
most moment yeah most muscle mass so
greatest opportunity to produce and
concentrate lactate and other
metabolites but when you get when you
get the burn going in the arms it's just
that much better yeah the more that you
can drive through the plate with the
heel of your foot the heel will avoid
the more that quadricep you're gonna
engage and you'll feel the burn go up in
the process gotcha yeah yes your heel
more than your front of your foot I mean
you don't need to over emphasize it but
when you have that flat force or when
the forces kind of spread out through
the whole bottom of your foot yeah
you're engaging more of the quadricep
producing a little bit more lactate and
we're just sending that much stronger
signal to the pituitary so if you think
about exercising without compression the
lactic acid is constantly swept away by
the venous system by the blood so to
create a comparable concentration of
lactate you need a Buster but for in
many cases over an hour of pretty
intense at work and that's what's so
unique about this is in a matter of a
few minutes most people feel the burn
that they would normally feel towards
the tail end of a workout without being
out of breath without
being overheated you know still being
able to have a conversation through the
process yeah yeah just being able to sit
here and feel what you're saying yeah
I'm trying to understand what's going on
biologically and physiologically like
you're describing yeah that the venous
system is unable to sweep away the
lactic acid because of the pressure
because we're reducing that superficial
blood flow which would normally be
sleeping away the lactate throughout
your exercise yeah and when that's
happening you really need to put in
significant wear tear time effort to
produce the concentration strong enough
that'll trigger your body's production
of anabolic hormones so here we are
through the first sprint keeping it
going first ones the hardest one nice
there we are we're in the range
excellent nice work
you got it 10 more seconds
here's our high intensity intervals
nicely done alright so now we're gonna
slow it down so much slower than the
pace you are currently warming up that
you want the Watts below 30 for the new
secular to you okay perfect
you know even more even more the fun
part about usually right about now is
when you feel the burn increase quite a
bit actually as you disengage from that
first sprint you kind of muscles relax a
little bit the burn in many cases kind
of shoots up and it feels like they're
doing a weighted squat or riding your
bike straight up a mountain which is a
weird dichotomy of things because it's
at a lesser resistance and a lesser
strats per minute uh-huh that's what it
would be like to be on the lowest
setting on the bike lowest gear setting
and pedaling up slowly yeah yeah and
then what we were doing the in the high
intensity was we were pedaling very very
quickly trying to get up much faster out
of lower gears feels like a higher gear
and it'll Esser strides per minute so
the resistance is much less right now
oh yeah but because that's right you've
sort of disengaged from the sprint the
cuff is able to tighten up just a little
bit because the displacement of the
water from the the muscle engagement and
then it further compresses the lactate
produced during the sprint so it's
actually when people disengage in
between the Sprint's that they'll often
feel the burn even even more than during
the spring yeah that kind of felt okay
I'm gonna analyze that this time yeah
got it so the next sprint is gonna be
half as long 15 seconds of Mourne time
but the trade-off is is there's two
additional levels of resistance okay so
you just did thirty at ten we're about
to do 15 no 3815 at ten now there it is
a little bit more keep going keep going
nice you got it
five seconds all the way through I don't
know what Peter's talking about no
sweating so we have some sweating still
I put you on a on a fairly challenging
protocol and so there there might be
some preparation that's still apparently
considerably less honorable a place like
if we weren't cooling you actively
cooling you throughout your body you
might be dumping buckets I'm assuming
when I extra situ I'm here I'll still
glisten I'll split up a little bit yeah
but you know in the rnd days I did this
without the cooling before and cooling
like you said is what is 45 degrees
Fahrenheit yeah and it's all around my
all around my body especially on my back
and so I'm sweating way less then I
would be when I was because I'm I'm
super hairy too so I sweat all along you
guys know how hairy I am you're like I
noticed that yeah I'm sweating way less
yeah yeah and I felt that burn I really
did feel when I got off of the high
intensity interval that's into the cool
so the cooling does a number of things
one is it actually helps mitigate some
of that discomfort of rapidly
concentrating lactate in the muscle
uh-huh
it lowers the perceived level of
exertion during the exercise was it
actually important so it makes this
whole experience a lot more pleasant
yeah otherwise yeah and even more than
that is it enables you to perform at a
higher level like we spoke about earlier
you know it's instead of all that blood
being shunted to the surface of the skin
to help facilitate respiration and cool
yourself down we're able to keep more
blood in the working muscle which means
we have more oxygen in the working
muscle which means
can perform at a higher level create a
stronger physiology to drive the desired
effect yeah so this is this is like a
way to harness your foundational
biochemistry to influence your endocrine
system okay that makes sense
well let's unpack that is pretty yes are
you crushing it yes nice work
okay so run us through that one more
time biochemistry and endocrine system
so by again reducing that blood flow
rapidly concentrating lactic acid and
other metabolites the strength of that
concentration is the signal that your
brain receives yeah to restore the
muscle to the exercise state so we're
essentially mimicking the physiology of
a much more intensive workout yes your
brain is responding accordingly I got to
rebuild the the muscle to the pre
exercise state pre-exercise condition
anabolic hormones dump they flood your
body and it's a systemic benefit that
we're working to elicit so we're
actually optimizing the entirety of your
endocrine profile it's not just the
increase in anabolic hormones that's
significant it's also the decrease in
cortisol specifically nighttime cortisol
cool yeah that's crucial so that's what
correlates with the improvement in sleep
quality which again is the most common
and immediate benefit that people report
do is decrease cortisol yeah huh yeah by
very significant degrees actually and
sometimes the the drop in nighttime
cortisol can actually be more
significant than the increase in
anabolics I had a good sleep after bass
burped I can't tell you how many people
tell us that I mean I'm excited to do it
sleep again tonight absolutely and it's
important to get eight hours of sleep
though you know more eight hours is
great if you can do it more important
than the quantity is the quality of
sleep is how much time you're spending
in the REM cycle you know that's where
that true rest rejuvenation and healing
occurs so I think you know four or five
hours of great rest is better than nine
hours of crappy sleep yes yeah there is
so when you call that one's intense
that's a good one
we're getting there we're 13 and a half
minutes in so three more Sprint's three
more Sprint's to 30s and a 15 to 30 to
15 you only got a minute 15 of hard work
left yeah this is awesome
at this point I'm gonna assume you got a
pretty steady burn going in the quads
super steady burning applause yeah so
it's the consistency of that burn that
most people are on accustomed to like
yeah cuz normally I only get this burn
when I'm doing my squat get the end of
it I don't
yeah yeah on that eighth and ninth
threat yeah it's like full fire in your
quads and it's a feeling that most
people associate with slowing down with
taking a break
yes whereas here we're pretty much
maintaining it at a fairly constant clip
for 21 minutes so the first session
especially you can take a little bit of
getting used to yeah I can't tell you
how many like you know accomplished
athletes will be halfway through on
their first sprint they're like I don't
know if I can finish this and in every
single case they can when people come
back for the second session you know
they have it under their belt they know
what to expect
and again we have we have clients in
their late 90s who are benefitting
tremendously from this as well the
you're explaining it so well because
right when we're finishing up our
workout those last couple of reps and
we're putting the bell down or the stack
of weights down that is the moment that
we go oh that feels good I'm so sore
right now yeah and then it goes away
yeah it goes away but right now I have
this lasting feeling going on yeah on my
muscles totally and it's lasting even
through this low part of the through the
interval part interval that's really
sort of a mind trip when you first feel
it yeah yeah all right here we go nice
nice job washing it oh you got this here
we go over halfway final ten seconds
strong finish all the way through that's
how you know that is good stuff holy cow
when you can spell your name with the
red line that's when you've turned throw
on when you can spell your name with the
red line all eyes then you can actually
yeah it's hey Taylor - you're crazy I
just get funny be able to do that yet
I still make a joke on everybody's for a
session though oh yeah I just get your
name into it so give me a give me an
idea of what the what does SPM mean
strides per minute strides per minute
cool so you're watts is a formula that's
generated between the resistance level
and your strides per minute okay
and that's not as a rough estimate make
sense you have power output yep yeah cuz
right now we're on resistance level four
correct in between the sprints and then
when we get to this 15 second it'll
automatically jump up to ten to ten boom
you hit it hard for 15 you know we bring
it back down to four and then again
you'll have that final 30 second sprint
at level eight I love late yeah and then
what are the levels goes from zero to
what 15 13 exactly yeah so there's
probably 30 35 different protocols
within the software with variants around
sprint frequency duration and intensity
and so forth on how good the athlete is
right it depends on what type of a
workout you're going for as it fits into
your routine that day yeah you left the
night before your goal is tomorrow yeah
so we'll make those adjustments for
people all the time a lot of athletes
will approach this as
of an active recovery tool an active
recovery system nope where they're you
know stimulating a response from the
endocrine system that's gonna help them
recover from the much more significant
workload that they're putting in outside
of the bachelor so that's where this is
this force multiplier where it's
optimizing your endocrine profile for
the greatly enhanced performance much
more significant gains from the work
that you're putting in and it greatly
expedited and enhanced recovery you know
in the same way that steroids would help
you in all three categories this is
tapping into your body's endogenous
production yes yes yes yeah yep
endogenous not exogenous so all coming
from within and also so the guys have
mentioned the endocrine system a bunch
so that's where you said the patooie but
to do a pituitary pituitary gland is
secreting growth hormone to the areas of
the body where there's a high amount of
lactic acid so the pituitary is in your
brain yep and growth hormone is the most
abundant hormone secreted by the
pituitary glands
okay and it's released in response to
intense exercise and deep sleep and deep
sleep so this essentially just zeros in
on the science of rejuvenation through
exercise and is engineered to maximize
that effect at a lower threshold and am
i doing that same thing during the deep
sleep am i getting the growth hormone if
you are if you are effectively making it
to that REM cycle and you're getting a
quality sleep absolutely yeah and
hopefully in response to today's session
you'll get a particularly good night's
rest tonight which is again across the
board everybody reports that I need to
learn more about the endocrine system
and the vascular system both just the
human anatomy in general we don't talk
about that enough like the GI tract
we've had microbiome analysis on here
it's all connected it's also connects
all absolutely connected
and your hormones and your endocrine
profile is is at the foundation of
almost every pro season system in your
body yeah a lot of people are suffering
from chronic chronically elevated levels
of cortisol you know which correlates to
visceral weight gain belly fat
inflammation yeah or sleep yes
everybody's overstimulated overstressed
and they're not getting the quality rest
that they really need to rejuvenate
themselves and to heal so exercise helps
across the board on all of those things
and this is just a concentrated dose of
the most significant benefits of working
out mm-hmm yeah I'm chatting you up in
the middle of the spread high-five
nice dude holy last one you through the
worst of it so good I am feeling like I
just worked out for an hour fantastic
for sure we're gonna get you off to the
the best part which is immediately after
wheels you've been to a yoga class yes
you know how at the end of yoga you lay
there and samaan yeah this is our
version of that we're gonna elevate your
legs we're gonna put you on a cooling
pad you're gonna allow your breathing
and heart to come to its resting rate
yeah and it's gonna act as a transition
between the session the rest of your day
yeah and most importantly is we want to
send that hard stop signal to your body
to your brain
uh-huh the workout is over the intensity
is over let it know that you've
transitioned into a relaxation phase and
that can sort of help coax along that
down stream anabolic effect we're
looking for yeah so you're the the same
thing I like how you come made it
relatable to yoga in the sense that it
is with yoga when you lay down at the
end of class yeah that's you telling
your body hey we're done with yoga relax
now and it's the same thing here we're
telling our body especially our
pituitary gland to it's an opportunity
to sort of integrate the physiology and
integrate
benefits yeah it's that integration yoga
it's an extremely important process it's
the same idea here yeah like you said
it's a stepping stone into the rest of
them apps love the day so at the very
minimum we want you to be on there for
five minutes to allow your your
breathing and heart to come to its
resting rate cool on and then yeah we'll
take it from there
eat it awesome 21 minutes 105 average
walks 95 95 strides per minute 1 182
sprint strides per minute sprint average
wat awesome and then you can email
yourself a summary you can yeah we have
some much more exciting analytics that
are in the works for the software I'm
excited to hear about these analytics
yeah there's some really cool stuff
that's in the works right now well let's
get you on the cooling bed I am I am so
sore so right now you're gonna feel the
burn walking from here to the chair or
to the table when you get off the table
you'll be surprised at how much better
you feel immediately so we're just
getting the cooling bed plugged in wow
this is great
so this analytic system so I'll be able
to get this full table of results in and
then I'll be able to see maybe a
day-to-day but much more exciting tell
me more yes tell us more this this data
set is not particularly exciting what
we've captured here is your average
watts for the entirety of the session
yeah and then your you know average
sprint watts your average strides per
minute and then the average strides per
minute during your sprint so it's it's
some metrics with respect to your
performance and if your to do the same
protocol consistently and yoni or your
Sprint Watts average is increasing you
sort of note that increase in strength
and endurance okay so you're seeing
yourself grow over time in a very crude
basic data set you are what's what's in
the works and what's very exciting and
go ahead go ahead and lay down awesome
yeah do I feel the cooling coming in
feel the cooling in I'll lay down now
and so okay so give me more on the
analytics and then we'll talk about
what's going on here or we'll actually
be able to incorporate real time
physiological monitoring you know
measure things like the electrical
output of your muscle throughout the
workout oh wow so you've got to put
little measures for electricity yeah Wow
electrodes right there's some very cool
physiological monitoring integration
that's in the process that's in
development being able to you know
select your protocol the intensity the
modifications of it based on your heart
rate variability how you slept the night
before your activity level that day and
your readiness score for exercise so all
of this data being crunched in the the
meta data over time is actually really
really exciting we're going to be able
to have a much more informed educated
protocols to drive specific benefits
across different demographics so yeah
you get a pic what kind of your machine
learning can tell you what kind of a
workout you're ready for that day based
on your sleep and your levels of
previous days of work out precisely and
there's there's some really great pieces
of tech that can help you know that
awesome yeah and so what's going on
right now so I'm laying on the same like
45 degree cooling pad it's going all the
way from my calves to the to my head to
the back of my head we got the back of
your neck cooled which is really
impressive blood flow yeah there
my legs are elevated they're elevated so
we can get that good low back contact oh
yeah by elevating your legs you get the
the back contact on there the entirety
of the back is being cooled the back of
your legs so this is really effective
and pulling the heat out of you it's
almost like a dry cold plunge as you're
laying here just like a dry cold point
exam there's there's some very
well-documented benefits to intermittent
cold exposure with respect to
norepinephrine production you know
glutathione production the reduction of
various inflammatory markers as well as
what it can do for your metabolism so
some of the benefits of cryo and and
intermittent cooling are also built into
this system and it's the synergy between
all these different elements between the
blood flow restriction the way that it's
delivered through the pooling the wide
liquid-filled cuff in conjunction with
that 21 minute interval based workout
that's really what sets us apart it and
makes this such a powerful platform I
think what you described with the with
the legs being elevated and having the
back fully laid flat and the pelvis laid
flat is so important I think we
frequently missed that when we try and
target the whole lower body that this
aspects really the really crucial yeah
you can feel you your respiratory rate
and your heart rate kind of dropping
back to its baseline oh Italy and it
feels so good nice oh yeah my heart
rates probably like 80 beats per minute
right now yeah yeah so I always I always
you know encourage people to as much as
possible get in a nice deep meditative
state yeah do some deep breathing
introduce some more oxygen into their
bloodstream
and when people leave you know they they
commonly report what we refer to as the
vas per hi we got that same post-workout
sort of not just in an endorphin rush or
release but just real true sense of
well-being mm-hmm your your calm and
peaceful and energized at alert at the
same time yeah it just feels like
everything's worth working in brains
turned on but in a beautiful way exactly
so we offer the first three sessions for
free and we've been accused of acting
like drug dealers that way our drug
dealers you even texted me and called it
a bass / not vas / da yeah because we're
based out of the NASA Ames Research
party love because of our relationship
with NASA you know people who are
regular people who own a system they're
referred to as vast for nots and I love
that I officially part of the squad I
love it yeah bad for not for life yes
for everyone that's watching that is
involved in these different sectors
where this could be applicable so
everything from the Army all the way to
athletes to hospitals what other sector
am I missing any type of rehabilitation
any type of physical therapy any type of
you know movement is usually the part of
most people's healing regimen and in the
case that somebody's physically
compromised and can't engage in regular
exercise this can be a revolutionary
powerful platform yes so any type of
healing rehabilitation geriatrics
physical therapy means even being used
in great success and things like cardiac
rehab in Texas there's a few hospitals
that are doing some amazing work with
vascular and then of course professional
athletics Human Performance company of
professional athletes special forces
NASA astronauts anybody that's having to
perform at a high level
it's an incredible thing that's going to
support you and then there's a
tremendous amount of entrepreneurs and
people that recognize the value
proposition you recognize the importance
of an optimized endocrine system you
know all of your quality of life life
performance for cognitive for everything
yeah and and there's we have a number of
these in private homes yep yeah so
whether your private home or anything in
physical therapy or rehabilitation or
athletics then just vast bird um we have
the link in the bio we there's currently
selling the system's forty five thousand
dollars for a system right now and then
you can you can get the system in to any
one of the centers so for use for a
private home or for in a center use for
for lots of different people and
different reasons and you guys maybe we
can mention some of the other aspects of
the vascular medical technology that's
being pushed
whatever is we're able to talk about on
the show there there's some extremely
exciting research that's on the verge of
being public being published as well I
do have to say that my whole system yeah
you were saying the bass were not high
yeah when you leave I'm totally feeling
high right now
totally I'm feeling so good I could take
on the world
after I'm also very calm yeah so I'm
super vigilant but also super calm yeah
so the the balance and those two is
fantastic and then I can my physiology
feels really really put together right
now like that I actually stretched it to
some of its limits
yeah so you know that homeostatic
capacity being swung into one side and
now coming back to equilibrium feels
really good versus it just being static
all day totally yeah and you would be
amazed
with any consistent and regular use the
impact that this has on your athletic
performance and just your physical
well-being is really really incredible
so we see people you know coming back
and reporting personal records and
whatever their medium is yeah or just
doing things that normally they'd be
sore from for days afterwards and being
like you know feeling brand new
immediately afterwards so for some
people that's gardening for two hours
and their back doesn't hurt for other
people that's running a triathlon and
being fully functioning the next day Wow
yeah yeah that vast difference between
those two basically if you can benefit
from exercise if you can benefit from
movement then you are a vascular client
yeah you can benefit from an aspirin
which is everyone everyone can do this
is truly is for everybody it's universal
that way in its application and its
benefit it's not that bad it's the price
of a car and a lot of people when you
see it that way it makes sense you're
like oh if I'm buying a car
I should also potentially look into
buying something so that I live a
healthy day-to-day life for as long as
possible and feel this incredible
feeling definitely yeah yeah so you feel
like you're breathing in harness sort of
back to baseline at this point yeah my I
feel really really good awesome
I think this aspect of it is so
important I'm sure you guys went through
the rnd of just using the Machine and
then you were like oh yeah then this
this aspect when it's it's like you said
it's the yogic process of laying down
afterwards yeah yeah I mean I've
definitely done vascular and skip this
part and when you when you actually go
through the full protocol there's a
notable impact that total that this
transitional phase of laying down on
your back allowing your respiratory rate
to come back to baseline it's an
important part yeah
someone yeah I mean well how much time
do you usually do on the cooling time
people will spend as much as 10 15
minutes sometimes yeah most people I'd
say are between 5 and 10 minutes yeah
we're at what the 5 mark rate probably
at least yeah always 5 okay we'll do a
couple I can tell you exactly actually
and I think we went 10 man we're at 10
okay yeah or I'll do another minute on
here though I don't feel so good see 10
minutes that exercise was feels like it
was so much longer and this feels like
you're so much shorter well that's
that's the beauty of it is the whole
process is half an hour yup there is a
cumulative benefit with any workout
regime it's particularly true with
vascular in that maintaining that
optimized hormone profile for a
concentrated period of time that's
what's gonna produce the best lasting
results so if you can consistently get
on vascular three times a week yeah
tremendous benefit to be gained
typically people that own them in their
home just based on the access they'll do
it five six in some cases seven days a
week how often do you have to recycle
the water you know next to never there's
some slow evaporation that will take
place and the water level will very
gradually drop there's a remote sensor
within the tank reusing it will indicate
on the tablet yeah there's a circulating
pump so the water doesn't stay stagnant
so it's cold it's constantly in motion
you know and then I'll even treat it
with a little bit of iodine to prevent
algae you another thing
really sweet yeah it's kind of like a
waterbed yeah it's like a cold water
cold water dud which can be used
independent of a session on a hot day
and so on a hot day nice on its own yeah
it's true yeah it's like you said it
cold plunge of dry cold plunge precisely
yeah yeah oh wow I feel so good I know
that I'm gonna be very interestingly
sore you so you should you'll know in
your legs that you worked out but it is
not the same late onset of muscle
soreness that you would get from
CrossFit or a spin class or any other
type of intensive anaerobic fitness and
those those are all great things to do
this is much more low-impact we're not
breaking down muscle tissue in the same
way and that's where that lactic acid
can get trapped and create that delayed
onset muscle soreness here we're able to
concentrate it rapidly for the duration
of the protocol and that's why you feel
the burns so intensely you might know
that you worked out but you're not gonna
have any problem walking down stairs
there's not gonna be any type of painful
soreness whatsoever which most people
are surprised by with how intense the
protocol can feel when you're in the
chair know sometimes people expect
they're gonna be totally super mobile or
the rest of the day yeah obviously you
will not be yeah I don't yeah exactly I
don't feel that I don't let me stand on
yeah
you can come into a vast procession very
sore from other physical training from
an intensive workload and then be amazed
at how much better you feel and how
we're following your session mm-hmm yeah
yeah surprisingly right now normally
after leg day is really hard to do
things yeah and like right now it feels
good I'll report again later
tonight report again tomorrow with like
a comments letting them know how I slept
nice as well in the video I'll let you
guys know Peter you want to join us for
the ending sure awesome and kill them
all back in okay now Avast or not now
bastard on hopefully we can get more
people to become vast or not so okay so
for the people living in the Bay Area
you can go down to the NASA research
park yep Ames Research Park and go see
bass per their just show you your
driver's license at the gate you let let
them know you're going to vascular and
they will happily let you on base yeah
yeah initially if you type in vascular
systems into Google Maps that will take
you to our parking lot for ways and and
then you can also book on the website
book online book a website or password
online so for those that are not in the
Bay Area but that are interested next
time you're around definitely stop by
the research park would also online pass
around this link to the different
physical therapists to the different
rehabilitation centers to different
sectors of to the of the army or of even
private clients or all these different
types of sectors that are that can they
can use athletes so many different
sports organizations football teams
basketball teams baseball teams soccer
teams all we have a good network of
these types of peoples that we're trying
to funnel into you because what better
way to to mesh these networks than to
get them to their peak performance
faster
we actually have vascular systems in
different parts of United States Canada
and even Europe right now what cities
can people go in well if you if you go
to vascular calm and then on the right
upper corner it's a schedule a session
it'll tell you all of the locations and
how to get in touch with them so for
example if you're in London England you
can do vascular if you are in in Dallas
Texas or different places oh you know I
says you can do it as well yeah so it's
all on the website and all the contact
information is there so you can directly
connect with those facilities
boom it's even in different cities
around the world that's great
yeah you can go get your physical
session across those different cities
let's do a let's do a quick summary let
me see how I can do with this let me see
how I did okay so what we what what when
what normally happens with with children
as children are moving around a lot with
high energy and they have they're able
to have higher concentrations of lactic
acid within their muscles and then the
growth hormone from the pituitary gland
gets secreted to those areas for faster
muscle growth and rebuilding and
children already have a high level of
growth hormones so they're just boosting
that hormone level even more and this is
why children recover so quickly when
they get injured yes they recover very
quickly you don't really need medical
intervention and they're homeless and
capacity is higher and that's part of
what the endocrine system is about that
Anatomy their ability to go back to
equilibrium if they're a great example
of what it's like to have all your
anabolic hormone levels on board when
you look at their resilience their
energy levels their quality of sleep for
the most part
so we're this you know people have
referred to this as a time machine for
your physiology time especially if
you're later in life and and then so
then okay now that we get to this point
of being later in life as an adult and
once we get to the adult stage it
becomes more difficult for us to retain
a higher concentration of lactic acid
within our muscle because our venous
system our blood flow is taking the
lactate and moving it the limb is larger
the limb is larger it's harder to
concentrate lactate in other in a larger
area than it is a smaller limb yes a
child and then also Venus is constantly
trying to move it out there's three
things that take you backwards so number
one is the size of the muscle it's
bigger yes so you can no longer
concentrate like to get those levels at
the at that level that you could when
you were a child with a smaller muscle
the second one is that we're closer to
the adult height so your natural hormone
levels are slowing down because your
growth cycle is slowing down the third
one is that we don't have time to run
around all day yeah so every 10 years
after puberty that signal to the brain
gets weaker and weaker and weaker and
this is where the aging process moves
forward and you lose muscle tissue you
have osteoporosis at some point and if
you go to a medical professional and ask
them you know what can I do about this
in most cases they'll tell you this is
normal you're just getting old but the
truth is our hormones don't decline
because we age we age because our
hormones decline so what we're doing
here is we're by bio mimicking this
physiology of a child and concentrating
like the gas are under the compression
were hacking your brain into secreting
additional hormone levels because the
brain basically gets a signal you've
destroyed the muscle tissue which you
have not so some people have referred to
this as Fountain of Youth type response
yes so it's like finding a backdoor to
the endocrine system and the endocrine
system is the essence of your health we
can talk about you know digestive system
all of those are very important organs
but the endocrine
if you do the hormonal profile you can
you can know precisely how healthy you
are I'm in it I'm I'm in love with this
and I'm really excited to continue
propelling what you're building with
these hacks into human performance and
health to the rest of the world so
you're so welcome it do we need to get
this and like we said you know we were
talking about the beginning but sitting
is the new smoking and can we can we
mention any of the insight into what's
going on next no worries if not no no we
are developing this technology is sort
of developing on many different levels
and there's a saying that I think
everybody will agree with that there is
no end to better we can always do
something better so there's a Sebastian
described where we're introducing the
physiological monitoring platform to
this device yes and we are right next to
Google where a lot of people are
spending hours and hours coding on a
computer so we basically designed a
platform that addresses the movement it
sort of could be compared possibly
somewhat to a rowing machine however
that allows you also to move the blood
to control the core body temperature so
you don't have the inflammation from
being stead magnet and push blood
increase faster the performance to your
brain all the great things that we would
like to do we're sitting at a desk so
that's something that's coming down the
pike as well I'm so excited
that one is so exciting the next no I'm
so putting together a lot more of the
analytics that are going on here having
better insights into the data while I'm
doing it here and then also this next
iteration with when we're sitting down
and we're working how can we use vas for
a while we're work
oh my god and what is that gonna do for
our body and our blood flow I'm sure
that the way you know how when we
hunched over the desk and we work
sometimes our breathing becomes more
shallow and we seem to UM we're
concentrating our focus on that I feel
like when we're using vascular
technologies while we're working at the
computer it's gonna be a whole new
ballgame people are gonna be
concentrated in new ways they're gonna
have different feeling of their body
while they're working this is you can
measure that impact in the brain state
of the brain waves yeah the state that
you're in is very measurable and with
regards to moving the needle you know
where your productivity is is your
lifeline you know even a 1% difference
can be worth a tremendous amount and I
think we're gonna move a lot more than
that and we have to ask you at least one
of our simulation questions before we
get off the show just the one question
about what is the most beautiful thing
in the world what is the most beautiful
thing in the world
yeah living life to the fullest is the
most beautiful thing and
taking control of your own health being
proactive about health and that's where
you know we wake up in the morning and
it's it's an awesome day and when we
would go to sleep at night it was an
awesome day and we started all over
again so again when you look at children
the reason we are the children are so
much fun to be with is because they
don't have any hidden agendas they are
full of life when they laugh they truly
laugh and sometimes when we go through
normal life and normal challenges in
life and forget some of those wonderful
times and how we you know how it is to
be totally healthy and form only balance
and hormonal balance also leads to
emotional balance so that's when
everything comes together living life to
the fullest yeah what do you think
special beautiful things oh you know I
think I think experiencing true freedom
within yourself to express the entirety
of your being and share that with other
people and of course being in good
health is the foundation of that yeah so
when you when you're totally free within
yourself you empower other people to do
the same thing and the vibration of that
and that to me is for sure I've
absolutely loved having faster on the
show this has been a blast we're excited
to continue collaborating the future
costliness on my speeder thank you
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate you tuning in if you guys had
a good time share the content with other
people let's get this out to more people
this new technology being able to
biohack human performance and human
health also give us a comment below with
your thoughts give us a like give us a
subscribe go to bat for calm book a
session for yourself across the world
and everyone support us on patreon we
need continued sustaining the studio
sustaining amplifying the beautiful
creations and interventions and voices
of people that are changing the world
so join us there thanks Ron Vargas are
producing partner and we'll see you guys
soon and give it
you
you